our presentation up
and
starting now
all right
so this is a
slightly different format if you've been
to one of our recent program overview
webinars we're going to be taking a
different tack here today and talking
about
why you should pursue a career in cloud
computing what it is about this
particular sector that gives you
exciting opportunities really for a
high paying and a fast growing career so
I'm here today we're going to be talking
about cloud computing careers in the
field
opportunities for you be asking some
questions toward the very end after the
Q a but we'll talk about one of our
cloud computing certification programs
at that point
do put your questions into the Q a
within zoom and Greg and I will be able
to address those later in the session
and
I want to let Greg introduce himself as
a
our resident expert today uh
we had scheduled for Matthew David
unfortunately he was not able to attend
but Greg
has admirably stepped in and he will be
a great
expert in this area for you
no pressure Stuart no not under pressure
yeah
yeah so uh so basically I've been
working in the uh Computing field for I
don't know like 30 plus years I suppose
so starting off like in in super minis
and mainframes years and years ago but
that transitioned pretty quickly into
all of our equipment got available over
the Internet or what was the fledgling
internet so I fortunately was able to be
around when the first AWS uh resources
were made available to just normal
people normal businesses got involved in
that did a lot of training on a lot of
different Technologies in those days but
also a lot of deployment and development
work for mostly small and middle-sized
businesses at first and then later in my
career I was doing more like Fortune 500
companies when we would be talking about
what's the best way to take Legacy
application development and migrate that
into cloud-based application development
both as a brand new starting application
and also how to migrate the those
applications to Cloud that we had
already been developed uh going along
with that was all the people who were
using those applications people like
business analysts and in marketing folks
and sales people
operational people and understanding how
to train them to make the best use of
this new technology and new way of doing
things new way of thinking about things
so I was fortunate to do that and then I
got hooked up with simple learn a few
years ago most have been working with
Azure AWS and Big Data programs and a
little bit of the analytics uh analysis
programs for simply learned so it's
exciting to work with them it's exciting
to to work with the students who are
just getting started or trying to
reskill themselves so uh uh yeah I've
been in a lot of different roles so I've
got a lot of uh info when Stuart's ready
for me to dump it so right
and we'll get started with that right
now we're going to
I'm going to let Greg address you about
the cloud computing sector
yeah so uh
uh I'll just run from this slide here
I'll try not to read the bullets per se
but basically the origins I kind of
intimated a little bit earlier is that
back in the day you know it was
mainframes everywhere was mainframes the
mentality was build the applications put
it in this big this big piece of iron in
a data center somewhere and share it
with everybody and that worked pretty
well for a long time 60s and 70s and so
on and of course IBM was a big player in
that in that space I particularly worked
at a company called digital Equipment
Corporation I was a senior engineer I
was a senior trainer I was a senior
consultant with them before I left and
they had uh what's called the PDP 1170
series and the VAC CMS environments and
those started making a lot of Headway
into businesses to make it a little
easier quicker to adapt and put
applications out in front of the
business people that needed them that
evolved pretty quickly into the internet
when uh company would be sort of AWS
decided to make some of those data
center resources available over the wire
and all of a sudden you're dialing in
somewhere to try to get to your compute
trying to get to some storage and so on
and of course that took off like crazy
and uh I don't know Stuart you need do
you need anything
are you just breathing okay so
I I meant to mute myself no no that's
okay
no no that's okay so so in this in that
time I'm not gonna say it was super
exciting it was more politically heavily
charged because what they were competing
with was I had a trading company at the
time training and I was teaching netware
which was real common to make
distributed computing available in a
business and then Microsoft came along
and they started reproducing Windows NT
and Windows NT was the beginning of the
Microsoft uh Evolution into workspaces
to migrate all your applications to a
shareable platform Amazon came in on top
of all that and said hey why don't you
just use the compute resources we have
in the cloud it's on demand it's cheaper
it's easier to deploy it's easier to
manage all of that of course that one so
AWS is now what they are today and uh
and they're they've been matched up by
Microsoft's Azure uh Google plays in the
space with gcp and then IBM's got
bluemix although I don't think they're
doing quite as well as IBM would like so
when I I work with IBM recently they
have made the wide decision very often
to just Leverage The AWS platform with
the IBM resources that they use so
there's three big big players now uh
well four including Legacy technology
but in general as I grouped through my
career learning all of this stuff I
didn't I didn't want to work Legacy
technology any longer other than to help
move it move it to Cloud that's all I
wanted to you know do so you had to pick
a cloud AWS treasure so when I'm
teaching courses for simply learn I like
to make sure students understand the
pros and the cons of each don't get too
married to one or the other because
they're equally balanced in a lot of
ways there are some things that are
better than others and for someone who's
getting into business you want to be
able to take a fair and balanced
approach to what's the best place to put
some some applications some data storage
and so on even up to and including do I
want to keep it in a legacy Data Center
and if so why so all of those things
would feed into the various types of of
technologies that would be used for for
example the software as a service that
might get utilized or you're just going
to pick a software package like
Salesforce servicenow there's some very
major platforms that a lot of companies
use and those are two of them uh the
platform as a service technology which
is a technology that are provided by
both actually all three major clouds you
can use them as a platform and minimize
your management effort and of course you
can say hey I just want some some
infrastructure I just want some compute
I just want some storage until recently
you had used the virtualized version of
compute and the virtualized version of
storage and so on but the bigger clouds
have now made actual Hardware available
in cloud like some of the earlier
adopters of cloud technology so as as a
specialist or as a cloud computing
engineer you have to know a little bit
about each of the things I just talked
about you don't have to be expert but
you should kind of know where they fit
and then anything as a service is just
whatever they dream up next and if you
go and if you want to find out about the
news about how how to do that you can go
to the the events that the major players
hold usually a couple times a year or
more or you can read about it in a lot
of the magazines that you see here info
world's a great resource you don't have
to subscribe to it necessarily because
they have a lot of online resources
Wired Magazine you can go there Network
World CIO magazine and by the way you
don't have to be a CIO to get CIO so
I've been getting CIO for years and I've
never been a CIO so there's a lot of
different resources that are available
and Google searches your friend uh in
the classes that I teach I'm almost
constantly if I say a new word a new
technique I'll whip out a Google
searched location on the web that
explains what that is and why you might
want to use it because there's a there's
the new word for almost everything
almost every day it seems like so in the
area of news there's a lot of ways of of
staying up to date of course one of the
best ways is to make sure you have you
take periodic training so as I said I
took when I first started I had it seems
like I had training I don't know for a
year and a half two years just just pure
training at technology companies and I
took some courses in college and uh the
the training that I found was the best
was the ones that had to do with
Hands-On things that I would actually be
doing in in the workplace so that's
where I usually encourage people to get
training from and then of course there's
all sorts of folks out there who who you
might look up to or follow on Twitter if
you want to I don't know how often Larry
Ellison tweets but
um some of the things that's on the
sheet there you see are are kind of
interesting to read and think about as
you get further into the technology
space so cloud computing is not only a
future of computing but the president
and entire past of computing of course
Larry's a you know multi-billionaire so
you got to kind of take what he says
into consideration
um mark benioff from Salesforce and
again Salesforce took over their space I
mean they're so good at what they did
it's a great company to work for by the
way but he uh Mark benioff said the
cloud services companies of all sides
the cloud is for everyone the cloud is
democracy and that's pretty true most of
the things that you want to use as a
fortune 1000 Fortune 500 you can use as
a small business you can use at home as
someone who's just learning you can get
a big data cluster you can do heavy duty
analytics a lot of the things these big
companies do you can do on your own so
it's really it is really a democracy and
then the last one there the um from
Deloitte Deloitte of course is one of
the big accounting firms there's several
of them Deloitte uh
pricewaterhousecoopers uh what's another
one well just those two I'll start with
so this one is uh it says the clouds
effect within business world may be
relatively clear but its impact on
society is just starting to be
understood now witness the whole
controversy with chat gpat right now
very controversial and who drives that
cloud what in Cloud drives that big data
and massive amounts of compute and
storage drives that whole Chat gbt thing
so the leaders therefore have a
responsibility to recognize the
implications and help share their their
address properly and of course chat gbt
is a good example of something we don't
really know if we even want to do it or
not but we're doing it anyway
and in terms of the the acceleration
since I started doing this I remember
like Amazon was happy to sell a little
bit of compute and S3 back in the early
2000s and now this SAS Market alone
Salesforce servicenow businesses like
that is expected to grow over 430 some
odd billion dollars next year so you're
and you're after that the past Market
platform is a service where you do a bit
more work but you get a lot more
flexibility it's slightly to see a jump
to 88.1 billion in 2025. and when
Gardner when Gartner jumps in if you
don't already know this you really
should pay attention to what they say
because when they say they predict
spending on public Cloud it's going to
jump for 242 billion to 692.
in public Cloud they're saying that
based on a significant amount of
research querying cios querying the
leaders in the business field so a lot
of times if you want to know what's
really going on for real in the world
you you can go look at a Gartner report
of course for the very great reports
they provide they charge for those but
they make a lot of stuff available
freely on the internet we'll talk about
this incredibly powerful growth curve
it's not growing like you know like this
one thing growing up or two things
growing up it's like all these things
growing you know together in parallel
and that's what Stuart saying about the
different opportunities in cloud
computing you used to just pick oh I'm
going to go into the computer science
okay well that's this right here and
then you're going to go cloud and that
was that like there now I'm going to go
to application development and big data
processing and all the other things as
well so just understanding all of the
different options it takes a little bit
of effort mostly so you can figure out
what you are attuned to what what thing
do you feel like you could be good at
because no one's really good at all
these things you might be able to do a
fair amount of them but you want to
start toning it down at some point
so the that's our transition into the
discussion about the
careers perfect
yeah so so yeah so you have all these so
can you can you go off and do a little
bit of research to find out what you're
good at can you hop on a cloud and try
different things out and say is this for
me or not so the first category for a
lot of people is the cloud engineer and
a cloud engineer would work on the
infrastructure of cloud computing used
to be the guy even even like me I used
to go in the freaking data centers and
sit there and listen to the air
conditioning gun for eight hours a day
ruined my hearing this horrible
environment and sitting there and make
the computers work make them talk to
each other and make them share data now
you just sit back and you comfort of
your home or your office on your laptop
and you're a cloud engineer allocating
resources in a virtual environment a
virtual world so you would allocate that
then you hand off the work to the next
group of people which is a cloud
developer and so a lot of times these
two categories sometimes they'll merge
but a lot of times they're completely
separate where developer is going to
know how to take software they'd like to
write that are going to take the tools
they like to use like Visual Studio or
vs code or eclipse in the Java world or
Pi spark in the spark world and they
learn use those tools well to create
applications very frequently locally and
then deploy them out to the various
clouds so once they're out in the Clouds
of course now someone's got to know how
to keep them working from the point of
view of can I get that set of resources
that you just built and that solution
you built in the hands of my business
users so the cloud administrators make
sure security is right big big category
of knowledge is cloud security a data
management data architecture Master data
management are all words that directly
relate to the people who focus in on
Data engineering so there's like
security there's data engineering
there's application development there's
devops and you probably all know about
devops devops is super hot because it
drops the cost of doing software
development maintenance way down if you
do it right and of course to do it right
you have to have a little bit of
knowledge about what the tools are and
how to use them so there's a lot of
different
um skill sets involved that are directly
related you can kind of bounce around a
little bit and then you can focus in on
one so one of the ones that you get to
after you've bounced around a little bit
which is what I was primarily doing was
Cloud architecture and that means that
you're going and you're listening to the
business use or you're looking at the
Legacy platform you're thinking a bit
you're saying how could I take that and
make it work better in cloud and then
like a building architect you would
build up the scaffolding which is all
the infrastructure build up the software
as a service as appropriate because you
can't pay for everything to be developed
and you put it all together and then you
hand it off to the database
administrator and say Here's the
scaffolding Mr DBA could you come and
make sure all the data is correct it's
secure it's accessible if you've got a
master data management strategy let's
make sure we Implement that and then
once you got those then you can go
walking over to the devops guy and say
look I need to have a prototype I need
to have a proof of concept that this is
going to work and I want you to pick the
language Java C sharp python r scale up
whatever it is and I want you to develop
something to prove it works and then
we're going to go give it to the cloud
security team and they usually they'll
have one or more Cloud security
Engineers that make sure all the other
three people are doing things the right
way because it's pretty easy to cut
corners and try to make it work because
honestly a lot of courses including the
ones I teach that's what I tell you to
do just make it work then once you have
it working properly secure it because
trying to build a security at the same
time causes things to not work a lot of
times so you can design Security in at
the beginning as you should and then you
give it to the security guy and he'll go
around and check the periphery check
call us attack surfaces they call them
attack surfaces for vulnerabilities and
if he finds them he'll report it back to
Cloud DBA the cloud architect the devops
engineer and say okay you need to polish
these areas there's a little bit of of a
of a hole here and then you go off and
do that so the this group the PC here
all end up working together sometimes in
really small companies it's the same
person which if you can avoid that do
because trying to do all of this with
one person is not easy uh but boy would
you learn a lot if you were doing it so
there's a lot of different related
Technologies but wasn't on that slide
was the analyst person then that analyst
person is the person that goes in looks
at all the data figures out how to make
it meaningful to a company like a
company like LinkedIn for example so and
Linkedin would say well you know we we
developed a fair amount of these Cloud
architectures we developed a lot of the
Technologies being used and then they
can go through and then now utilize the
whole lot better so you can pop back to
the LinkedIn slide
um so the the LinkedIn so when they say
we're developing things well they're
developing things and then they have to
deploy them globally this is a big
company so they're saying that LinkedIn
was 213 000 Cloud openings in the USA of
as March 2023 and I believe that I mean
I've been LinkedIn I've been on LinkedIn
since it was created pretty much and
it's just it's grown tremendously the
number of jobs are going tremendously uh
companies countries like India country
um actually almost every other country
they're uh growth pattern in the area of
cloud computing is huge because it just
makes sense the business people who make
the monetary decisions on how to spend
money to keep track of data and
applications realize that in most cases
a cloud strategy is the most cost
effective so the growth of it is
expected to be through the ceiling 23
percent through 2025 and if you go and
if you go listen to the vendors who sell
all this stuff they'll tell you pretty
much the same thing they're they're like
this and by the way sales is another
good job I've had I've been a sales
support engineer in my past as well
where you need to go in in the business
it's not quite sure what they should do
if it's safe or not they should spend
money so all this Cloud growth means
that somebody's making a decision to
invest in their Cloud strategy so it's
really fun to take some Basics and go
talk to them and the reason I bring up
the sales teams once you got a good
overview of things it's a really great
place to kind of fine tune and own that
because you usually talk about a lot of
different things when you're looking
into the the growth aspect of cloud
which would include sales and you can't
be ignorant of the Technologies in the
companies you got to know what's going
on
so like all the companies you see on
this slide they all hire I mean I've
I've worked with and and known people
pretty much everyone that's on that
slide list so IBM for example I know for
a fact IBM when they're looking for
things they like to get interns they
like to get people who are are excited
about the technology able to express
themselves clearly and understand how to
take a problem and do a bit of a problem
solving pass the problem back I've had
great great work with uh with IBM the
same thing with Accenture and Deloitte
the two big uh six accounting companies
uh worked with them uh I've used them as
Consulting uh companies and businesses
I've been working with and what they
bring to the table usually is again
people who they they've gone and vetted
out cross-trained into the way they do
things in the cloud space and make sure
they knew how to talk about it so if
your expertise is going to be big data
your expertise is going to be Cloud
architecture they they typically will
have you hone in on one thing until
you're pretty good at talking about it
and then they involve you in their in
their um businesses with their their
customers same thing with Tata over from
India Tech Mahindra these are companies
that were fairly small 10 years ago I
don't know small is the right word but
they weren't humongous like Deloitte and
Accenture and they've they've been great
inroads into providing Services globally
so I've used those folks Oracle goes
without saying is all over the place and
so is emphasis so we Pros the one I
haven't used as much but it needs a case
the point is these companies they know
they know they're not going to go out
and get a senior architect or a senior
database administrator
all the time sometimes they'll get that
role but a lot of times they know
they're going to have to start at the
beginning bring a team develop invest in
them and grow them up so they're looking
for people who are excited they're
looking for people who know how to say
what they want where they want to go and
that is one of the things you want to
get if you're going to take a simply
learning course I almost always
encourage students to go off find
someone to peer with and sell them on
what you just learned you'll be boring
as heck if you do it at a party so don't
do it at a party but get you know if you
get together and you can share stories
back and forth about how things work
debate back and forth about whether it's
good or bad excellent and these all
these companies on this page would like
that I can tell you that with certainty
so then you say well where can I make
the most money everybody wants more
money than you know they're making today
so the the the uh you'll find different
salary averages in the USA in the uh the
UK uh all the European blah blah blah
this particular one is from the USA and
as you can see it's kind of broken down
from entry to senior level
um I will say that since I've been a
hiring manager at more one of the
companies that I've looked at those are
pretty accurate you know the entry-level
an entry I I had a student that I I
worked with when I was doing some some
uh teaching at a local University just
because I wanted people I need smart
people so I offered to take some free
seminars on Cloud on the company I was
working with at the time
I wasn't really there to try to teach
per se I was hunting and I found two or
three people I said these guys are sharp
they're engaged I give them things to do
they go read it they research it they
come back so I managed it out of that
one session of people maybe 30 people in
that group I managed to directly hire
his interns at an 80k level or higher
four of them four of them for four
different kinds of roles because I was
looking for people that were in were
engaged and that was one of the ways to
find them so for yourselves that's you
want to make sure you get yourself out
there because that's the entry level the
cloud developers a little bit lower
because you're just you're doing
software development and that will get
you where you want to go eventually if
you look at the senior pricing range for
that but it's not going to be as high as
Cloud engineer or Cloud architect so but
you can bounce around as well I've been
personally a cloud engineer I've been
Cloud developer and I've been Cloud
architect now when you can choose
between all three you tend to
settle on the one that makes the most
money that's most fun for you so if you
look at the senior numbers out there are
those achievable at least right now in
the current market space they they
definitely are the 271 for a cloud
architect is on the high end I will say
that but there are high-end jobs out
there for people with 10 15 years in our
architecture some business Acumen and
that architect has often done the cloud
engineer job and Cloud developer job so
they understand what's necessary how to
Mentor other people into developing the
kind of platform that you're looking to
do so all the numbers on this chart I
think are pretty realistic and they
there's something that you should Aspire
towards and but if you do get something
a little lower as an entry level you got
to wait what am I going to get out of it
yep so now I'm done with that one so
that that's a lot of things to think
about when you go through that the the
up-to-date skills
what's kind of good about this job if
you train to be an accountant when
you're 20 you'll be an accountant when
you're 60. and you might learn some new
things but you're still going to be an
accountant if you get in to be a cloud
practitioner or anything in Cloud it
used to be that in the computer industry
you were cons you're constantly learning
you're going to learn uh Fortran then
you're going to learn coball and you're
gonna lose assembler then see
object-oriented analysis and design and
that was your path there weren't a whole
lot of variants now there's a lot of
variance I mean like I said before
they're all over the place so up-to-date
skills in how to pick a cloud again when
you're studying Cloud architecture or
Cloud uh in terms of AWS or Azure or
whichever one it is but what's what's
the thing what's the thing that that
cloud is good at what's the thing that
cloud is not as good at so selecting the
proper cloud and the cloud architecture
on top of that application migration is
huge I've spent at least three different
Contracting terms doing nothing more
than an application migration how do I
safely get your application set into
Cloud performance testing is a part of
all of that and Cloud workloads
understanding how to allocate enough
power in the cloud to get what you need
done accomplished is a big is a big
thing an important task that's going to
affect the actual cost I did the access
management it's just Cloud security
right so Cloud security if you're if
you've got that hacker mentality you
like to see how things work great place
to go highly in demand the auto scaling
functions a lot of companies are not as
good at Auto scaling as they should be
you know that means that you allocate a
little tiny bit of compute and then on
you know Christmas Eve when the Ecom
things are going crazy it scales up by
itself that's an important skill to have
a little bit weak in my experience in a
lot of different areas another area
that's huge is disaster recovery usually
that's an afterthought and for the
companies that make it in afterthought
and experience of disaster you know it's
not afterthought any longer but that's a
big one web services and standardization
and apis another important category if
you're a developer and you like to mess
around with code you already know what
web services are and you don't know what
apis are those are not an afterthought
you have to think of those ahead of time
so that you know how you're going to
scale them out and the same thing with
the last ones there Cloud migration
deployment database management uh
storage services that multi-cloud
deployment is a special case that means
that you're going to use the best of
azure the best of AWS the best of gcp so
and you know what those are so that was
uh I'll pass it back to Stuart and and
see if he's got any any comments
uh Zoom just kicked me off for a moment
so if you wanted to finish up on on this
slide
yeah I'm done with that one I thought
you would I thought you wanted to chat
uh I'm gone I haven't I haven't talked
for a few days so I've got lots to say
it's it's it's it's that Zoom sometimes
has issues with uh with me so it kicks
me off briefly but brings me back on
okay well we're good yeah so this this
particular slide is really important
because you're saying well what am I
going to learn what am I what do I need
to learn what I want to focus on and
when I'm teaching a class like on any of
these different topics one of the first
things I I let everybody knows I'm going
to tell you the things that you need to
focus on because in any course there's
the core juicy little pieces that you
kind of need to know and then there's a
fair amount of fluff and you can't you
need to know a little bit about the plot
but not a lot and so how are you going
to make that determination so this slide
helps point out some things that are
there's no fluff on its live so if
you're going to be learning cloud for
example then need to know about the
compute area of Amazon ec2 you need to
know how it works how to deploy you
should be able to go to a console spin
up a virtual machine access it and run
an app because that's a basic core skill
the same thing with doing a basic
attached to a database of some sort it
doesn't have to be Amazon's dynamodb
there's lots of other ones out there but
that's a really good one to start with
good support does a lot of different
functionality and then as you're using
compute you'll go you might go looking
around the slide there as you're using
commute do I go but it's expensive to
use ec2 well it is yeah so what if I
just use compute when I just when I need
it I only want to pay for running this
little application right here when I run
it I'm going to run it twice an hour
great we'll use AWS and Lambda for that
because that way you're not going to go
off and allocate a computer build it out
deploy it and pay for it forever you're
only going to use the Lambda compute
when you need it important concept then
I need to store the output somewhere so
you need to know where to store it on
Amazon it's S3 on azure's blobs so it
depends on where you are at as to how
you're going to store things you need to
know about that as well and then over on
the right hand side there you've got a
lot of technologies that are pretty
importantly as you're this that's
obviously on the Microsoft platform
actually all three of those are so the
Azure resource manager that will help
you manage the utilization tracking and
billing of all these services that
you're using then the Azure container
services which is a kind of a step
between an ec2 and a Lambda it means
I've got I've got a container I'm going
to put computer in that container and
I'm going to keep that container busy
all the time and when something breaks I
want to automatically fix itself pretty
powerful so as you might guess
understanding containers is an important
basis and then the last one is just
Azure and Azure domain naming Services
how to build it how to deploy it how to
make sure all your tools can talk to
each other globally and that would be
more the area of how networking Cloud
engineering but a subcategory cloud
networking also pretty exciting to to
get involved in
uh and then where it says and many more
or if you go to the AWS homepage or the
Azure home page and you click on the
services available oh my God there's
hundreds of them in there so it's uh
it's it's definitely a lot of services
that you can get
yeah I'm good on this one Stuart all
right so we've gotten to the point now
where we can uh
take questions from the audience
stop sharing and see what we've got
right now there's one question in the Q
a so I encourage everybody to to add
more but this first one from Roger
um I am currently a network engineer
CCNA and a ccnp
uh what would be recommended to become a
cloud engineer
yeah do you want me to take a first stab
at that yes please yeah okay well since
I used to teach netware for quite a long
time
um a good good on you because that's not
an easy course to get through but what
you want to do is your knowledge base
when you're a network or microsoft.net
industry either one of those two is to
take that transition that into Cloud
that that cloud engineering is more on
the area of architecture as relates to
building virtual networks deploying the
compute and storage resources that you
need so Azure fundamentals or AWS
fundamentals associate architect would
be would be areas to focus on as well
that's going to be almost a direct
correlation to what you already know so
that makes it easier to step in the
cloud and once you're sitting on that
perch of looking at engineering then you
can look around and see if there's
something else that's more interesting
to you okay
thank you um sanjana I saw you raised
your hand if you would put your question
into the Q a we'll take that in the
meantime from the chat um
uh I am a networking student planning on
taking AWS certified Cloud protection or
certification what
would I do next after that
how can I get into
more deeply into cloud computing
that's a loaded question what what um I
I don't see that written anywhere what
was the where is he right now
uh he is
a networking student and looking to take
AWS certified Cloud practitioner for as
a certification
but what path can he follow next to go
deeper yeah yeah well the good news is
the practitioner class is going to get
you kind of a broad based overview of
what L is in Cloud at a basic core level
so the the challenging part there is
because you started off with networking
you don't know maybe you more interested
in data you might be more interested in
software development you might be over
more student in uh project management
which I think one of the other questions
is there's a lot of different things
that you can then look at once you're in
that space the best thing to do is to
talk to other people in your class talk
to the instructor and figure out what
what you're interested in because
there's there's all these there's all
these different paths from that
practitioner level and you really kind
of need to decide do I want to be a DBA
if you don't like databases then don't
go do that if you like networking and
virtual networking you will be a cloud
engineer also security engineer also
someone who who specifies and both
deploys software as a service technology
in your company so there's a lot of
different things that you can launch off
to with that practitioner
certification that you can then become
you can become deeper Cloud architecture
is The Logical next one associate
architect and architect
and that leads into Peter's question
from the chat he was curious to know
what is the process and how long does it
take to get into the cloud architect
position
the
useful resources so you said Peter oh
it's over in the chat his question
literally is please how long does it
take to become a cloud architect
I'm not laughing at you I'm laughing
with everybody including myself
um you know it depends on the level of
knowledge a cloud architect is someone
who knows all different components that
you can use to build up a solution in
the cloud so the it's going to take you
the time it takes to go through those
courses whatever that is usually a
couple of three months at the very least
and then then the time it takes to kind
of in in
incorporate key Technologies into your
thought process and probably apply them
to a a problem or a solution that you're
developing for a company so and that
might take another year or two now if
you just want a job as
almost nobody in my experience would
hire someone who's relatively new as an
architect because the the broad the
breadth of knowledge is is pretty pretty
broad but they would hire an uh an
intern Cloud engineer who wants to be an
architect so you would want to take on
the skills of the cloud engineer
directly try to implement some of the
solutions and then speak about them in
terms of the architecture and that'll
get you going where you where you want
to go and you can pick any little any
little pieces that the company needs to
get you in that path you basically need
experience to become an architect right
uh Jean Philippe uh I think you touched
on this but what is the most important
cloud service AWS Google Cloud azure
uh yo just for Stuart just for Stewart I
wouldn't normally I'm going to do this
anyway so from I get that question all
the time in the classes right so and at
the companies so each of the clouds has
strengths and they each the clouds has
weaknesses so there is no one Cloud
that's better than the other
except for the exception of two AWS and
Azure both are probably better at
Enterprise deployments than Google so
gcp is a big data ml machine learning uh
AI kind of a platform they do have other
Technologies but the the oftentimes
they're the third cloud in the
multi-cloud environment so the second
Cloud if you're a Microsoft environment
and your legacy platform all around you
is all this Microsoft SQL Server active
directory Services Windows is everywhere
and you want to migrate to Cloud easily
and quickly and slowly I don't want to
do some some you know punch and switch
Azure is the best one in my opinion but
that's because I've used the different
clouds and Microsoft has tools and
Technology just makes it easier for you
to migrate to Cloud you can do it in AWS
and you have and I actually have done an
AWS but if I had the pick I'd pick Azure
now if I'm a brand new startup and I
want to use the best of everything I'm
probably going to pick AWS so it's it's
it you know you know why you like
certain things and why you you don't
that's the main story there don't go and
say hey Azure is better kicks aws's butt
don't go do that
um we have Josh who's a BCA student in
India
what course do you recommend for cloud
computing uh we actually have some
recommendations for you at the end
um so we'll be touching on that uh
jayash we're going to be talking about
one of the courses that's offered in the
us but we have an analogous course that
we offer in
India and the rest of the world as well
so
um
uh says I'm a pmo person work in scrum
Masters project managers program
managers fit into this space how do the
skills apply within Club yeah yeah I'm
I'm so glad you asked that because one
of the first things I I need I require
when I get into a project I'm going to
do a project I want a good pmo I
absolutely do you you get a bunch of
techy nerds in a room they can't you
know they can't screw a light bulb in
you know pretty much by themselves need
a good pmo and a good pmo takes the time
to understand the underlying base
technology so they're not an expert but
they've taken Azure fundamentals or AWS
fundamentals or if you're a big data
project you know they know what the
terminology in Big Data space is they
know what the the big components are so
if you're a pmo you have to pick an area
of technology that you're going to
become knowledgeable about and take the
entry-level classes for that
build that together as a part of your
story so you can say you're going to
participate in the solutioning as you
manage moving it Forward that'd be my
short answer to that
yeah as a techie nerd I take exception
to your characterization but the problem
with techie nerds and screwing and light
bulbs is
that the project management person will
tell the techie nerd you really can't
spend eight hours figuring out the
optimum weight to screw in that light
bulb got to yeah pick pick one that
works and move on so that's that's yeah
yeah I'll agree with you I'll agree with
you Stewart see that's how that's how
this works I I don't agree with that
being said by dude the principle I do
but we both understand that sometimes
the techie guy just wants to get it
perfect and I don't need perfect I just
need it to work for the business that's
the pmo's job and if everybody
understands that then you get along
swimmingly so uh anyway yeah sorry for
the Jive there's Stuart
uh Peter asks a great question which is
what are the relationships between data
science and cloud computing
yeah so uh again this is all opinion
right I could probably go Google
something and read something to you but
basically the data scientists in general
are a newer ad to a lot of businesses
they're typically expensive which is
good for you if you want to be one
because they get paid pretty well if
you're good at what you do you have a
short life span once you're a data
science and you scientist and you come
into a company that's got a whole bunch
of tableaus for doing analytics they've
got big data clusters and they want to
leverage all that they're going to give
you this much time to produce something
useful well you need this much time A
lot of times so being a data scientist
you have to be able to explain why this
amount of time isn't going to be good
enough you need this amount of time so
in other words a business usually says
it takes 10 hours to deploy a new
compute instance in such and such Cloud
right they'll do the same thing today
the scientists who's got a head full of
analytics and they understand all the
different permutations of the of the
algorithms are going to get used in a
machine language application to deploy
this great answer but they realize it's
going to take them a year to get it
right so you have to ask them and
yourself or you can really have that
year so it's it's incredibly important
and you have to get some salesmanship
skills and you need to fine-tune Rapid
delivery to meet the requirements of the
business even if it's uncomfortable
so that would be my answer
okay
today uh in the chat asks I'm busy
preparing for AWS certified Solutions
architect and you please recommend some
useful resources and preparation for
this and if you look at the
simplylearn.com website you'll find a
number of resources that are
specifically to prep for that course for
that certification
um
so here's Hillary who asks for advice
from the background of being desktop
support for almost eight years
would a pivot to cloud computing or
pivot to data analysis be better
well I've worked with a lot of desktop
support people I'm assuming you're one
of the better ones if you're even
thinking about this so a desktop support
person's primary skills that say are
willing to dig into things that other
people don't want to dig into uh they
have to go do some side research to
figure out what patch is required to fix
this problem and you got to have good
interpersonal skills typically so those
are the kind of things you would want so
if you're going to move that into into
Cloud you're going to end up focusing on
the more technical aspects of those
things because there's almost no job in
entry-level Cloud that's got the
interpersonal relationship stuff built
into it it's mostly do you understand
how to solve this problem using these
tools so I would probably you know do
the cloud engineering transition where
either Cloud engineering or data again
you got to decide if you if you like
pulling data into a spreadsheet and
analyzing it and figuring out what it
means think about the data path if you
if you like building up little tools and
wiring things together other than the
engineering crop so I can't answer that
specifically other than by saying that
so I would probably default without
engineering one yeah
um we had a couple last questions Wilder
asks can you become an architect without
going to University
of course almost all the good Architects
that I know including me I've been to
University I did I graduate not really
um so well I did I did but it wasn't in
a technical it wasn't in a technical
space So yeah so all almost all of my
training was either self-done
or it was done through jobs I inserted
myself into I was lucky enough to get
available and leverage them as much as I
could learned as much as I could
understood and cared about the business
requirements a lot of techies going to
the little office and they just want to
play what you got to do is you got to
leave your little office go off and meet
with the marketing people the sales
people the CIO the business line of
business owners understand their
problems and their issues if you do that
will enhance your skills as an architect
because now when you speak people will
listen because they know that you're not
going to blobbly blue ball every you
know in unintelligible sentences you
know and that's another thing to prove
that you're going in that path try to
minimize all the Techno speak that you
end up learning as you go through all
this put English words on each thing if
you're going to learn Cloud to
architecture learn the am the Azure one
if you look at the AWS one they have all
sorts of weird names for weird things
that don't mean anything to anybody if
you go the Azure route they've named
everything by what it really is doing so
the first terminology set I would learn
would be the Azure terminology set
knowing that Kinesis and elastic beam
stock isn't going to mean anything if
you bring it up in the business meeting
right so that's that's my advice here
okay
um and then I think it will take is the
last question here
um is
we have uh
shoddy asks to be
uh
let me State the question I am currently
transitioning into Tech and looking to
reskill by taking on cloud computing
we'd like to know if Cloud practitioners
required knowledge of coding
secondly what's the available support
post training so if you could take that
first one
what yeah coding knowledge that cloud
personing
that's that's a hot one and one of my
favorite things to bash on so I hear I
see all sorts of older style programs
that try to teach people Java for
example well someone who's a cloud
engineer or security or desktops or any
of those things if you're not a
programmer Java is not a good thing to
do because it's gonna it's gonna hurt
your brain if you want to learn a little
bit about coding if you want to learn a
little bit what it means to create an
application called API use a tool like
python python is is predominant in a lot
of architectures it's huge in Big Data
it's huge and just developing little
easy to use programs and the concepts
are all based on the same ones you got
in Java and the same ones you got in.net
so you could transition later if you
want to so I would start with something
like python minimize the impact of that
and see well can I just learn basic
scripting skills yes can you script in
Python yes you can so so you can use
powerstone bash and python all together
so you're going to learn a little
scripting in most of this technology
Cloud engineering or whatever pick a
language that's not going to you know
hurt your brain unless you want to be a
programmer if you want to be a
programmer or the net Java or Ruby on
Rails any of those are are good there's
a lot of them I'm not going to go into
those right now but there's a lot of
languages you could go down that path
most people come to a seminar like this
though want to do the work they want to
do the architecture they wanted to build
and deploy database they want to extract
transfer loads on databases clean it up
so that they can use it in their
business services and so on so I would
say I would say python I recommend
everybody at least do the basics of
python it'll tell you if you like it or
don't like it at least do a little
Basics simply learn mix of I think a
free version of the Python training
available for I think it's anybody so
you can just go do that and then you can
talk to your educational resource person
and they can tell you how to extend that
outwards but you would use that almost
any of the cloud-based forces and
generally speaking in in all of our
bigger programs which I'll speak about
one of them in a moment
um
any coding that you need to learn how to
do is included in the curriculum for the
program so unless it says that you have
to come in with a particular set of
skills that will be part of the training
that you receive
um and we'll also mention briefly when I
talk about that program some of the
posts training support that you get in
terms of
job search support and that type of
thing so
um Misty I see your question and you'll
hear about the answer to that your
question having to do with the hands-on
experience and Cloud tools you'll hear
about that in just a moment as I go into
that so that I'm going to wrap up the Q
a
and I'll move back into the presentation
and we'll talk about
one of the programs that simply learn
offers
here's my slideshow
again if I get kicked off for sharing
I will be back
well I still see you thank you by the
way thanks for the great questions too
by the way I appreciate that
yeah our audience today has a lot of
keen interest and a lot of great
questions so we're very very pleased to
have the interaction with you folks
um and here's our question for you
um the first of several
what is stopping you
from taking that step to get certified
in cloud computing
if you've looked at other programs well
I haven't you done them is it because
you can't find one that covers all the
skills that Greg described is it one
because you don't think you'd end up
with the Practical hands-on experience
to demonstrate your skills
is it because the learning style doesn't
fit you
learning from pre-recorded videos and is
it because you don't find the time in
your work schedule make time for
training and education so
let me
you were hearing from Greg's dog earlier
you may be hearing from my cat right now
um
in the poll here
share the results and the main issue
that most people have is feeling that
they would get
practical exposure worrying that you
wouldn't have the Practical experience
at the end of the program to show off
your new skills as well as finding
comprehensive programs and
finding the time to do them so
I'm just going to briefly mention this
program
this is one of many and this is one that
we do in conjunction with Caltech which
is one of the world's leading
universities Caltech has a center for
technology management education which
trains people in Industry on technology
and management skills and they've chosen
us as their delivery partner for the
cloud computing boot camp this program
is based in the United States we have a
different version that is
for India and the rest of the world that
covers similar curriculum but is a bit
longer
all the this program has
pretty liberal requirements I'll talk
about that in a moment and this covers a
fully comprehensive curriculum with the
Hands-On lab you do them in a sandboxed
environment on the same digital learning
platform so all you need is the machine
that has a web browser
laptop or a desktop to do most of your
work you can access some of the
materials on your mobile device
self-teaching videos in preparation for
your live classes you get live
instruction
trainers who will take you through the
the exercises usually those are weekend
classes so they don't interfere with
your work
you can see here this is the structure
of the program starting with an
induction session that teaches you what
you're going to learn how to use the
platform then it takes you through AWS
a couple modules in AWS and how to use
that and design and Implement Solutions
there then a couple modules on azure
taking you through implementation and
management of that platform
and then on the Azure platform chosen to
use that for the infrastructure module
a final
phase of this program is a Capstone
project where you build a solution to an
industry-based
a cloud computing Challenge and it'd be
the type of problem that you might be
expected to work on as a working Cloud
engineer and you get to build that
solution it goes into your portfolio
along with all the other projects you've
done in the course
as your practical experience so you get
hands-on experience with all the tools
and then you get to show what you did to
any potential future employer or to your
current employer to get a better
position
along the way you can take no extra
costing
master classes from Caltech instructors
which are fascinating
take some deeper looks into some of the
subjects so you can come into this
program this particular program the boot
camp again a U.S based program can come
in as a high school graduate
18 years of age or older you not need a
programming background you will learn
any coding skills that you need on the
during the program you also don't have
to have work experience
International Version does require that
you have a bachelor's degree
so it's a slightly different program but
for this one
for us and North America South America
Learners no bachelor's degree required
how much experience do our audience
members have I'm going to ask this
question real quick
just to get a feel
or who's still in school who's
been in the workforce for some time I'll
just leave this open for about 10
seconds
closed it in five four
three
two one
so about half of our audience are people
still working on their degrees and the
other half
are people
with work experience and
that pretty much tells you that nearly
everybody here I think is
qualified to take this program from the
educational experience point
and
I want to share with you a couple of
brief testimonials from Jorge who
um
finish the course three weeks later got
hired as a cloud engineer
doubled his salary
Mario has
gotten much more attention from
recruiters from
course and you were mentioning not on
the cloud course but on a different
course Greg you mentioned that a couple
of your students got job offers while
they were in the program I thought I was
supposed to talk about it yeah no no I
mean it's funny it's funny I I uh the
students I had more than half of them
got jobs in the space within probably
about the first two months of the
program and it's not just because of
that it's because the people who are
taking a class like this are investing
in themselves and a lot of employers
they they figure that out that's a good
thing to bring up during an interview
and in talking about your experiences
which I emphasize with these guys so
they would talk I would say take these
stories and I'm telling you that you're
learning right now and making your own
stories because that's what's going to
help you get a a job so anyway so they
got they got jobs right away one of them
as uh Stuart pointed out one of them
more than doubled is salary and it was
just like over the moon uh he continued
in the in the program and and one of the
ones I'm doing now they're just
finishing up and both people who are now
left one of them has a new job in this
plug-in along the other one's job won't
start until he's actually done with this
program but those are both amazing
amazing outcomes and uh it's just when
you do sign up make sure you let the
instructor will be telling you things
and sharing probably stories and so on
write those down right make those your
make those your own stories add that to
your experience somehow and so that when
you you get asked a question along those
lines you don't say I'm researching it
or I'm studying it right now tell the
story so I'm that's what I'm going to
encourage you to do is make sure that
you you take as much as you can from the
training program
also
and and that touches that leads into the
advice about the the job assist services
that are part of this boot camp for
Learners who are in North America
um
you get everybody
works with simply learn gets uh you know
the the projects the portfolio of things
that you've done in the courses and
capstones that you get to take with you
um you also all get access to webinars
that we do regularly to help you in
staying sharp technically and and with
career skills and job search skills
um specifically for U.S Learners with
this program and we have a version for
India Learners with our International
programs you get job assist Services
which give you exclusive job openings so
that extends for six months after you
complete that program
so
quick question here
two parts
and are you interested in
enrolling in this program potentially
and if so when
we'll just leave this open for another
10 seconds
a chance to hit submit
I will close it in five
four three
to
one
in the poll and share the results with
you
I'm looking at
three quarters of you are interested and
uh more than half of you who are
interested like to do either maybe in
cohort that we would start next month or
the next couple of months so that's
great and do reach out to us
ask us at simply learn.net I'm going to
put that into the chat right now
make that available to everybody
hold on for just a second as I look
I do want to tell you that if you um
enroll
after this session
we have a special bonus offer for you
you get more information about that in
our follow-up email but it's a
substantial discount on the boot camp
program so if you are eligible for a
North American program
um
mention that to you now in the chat you
can access
the email address and the URL for our
program
so the program fee is
9999 you get a 500 discount for
oops the next cohort starts with classes
in May and next week
is the uh
orientation session and you are going to
see me drop off and drop back on again
it's going to have one last question for
you
okay one last question for you
let's get to that oops
there we go
and
that last question is uh would you like
us to reach out to you and help you um
learn about getting enrolled would you
like would you if you want a proof of
attendance for this particular webinar
show that you were here today we can
also send that to you so if you answer
yes we can do that but
also answer yes if you'd like us to
reach out
and
tell you more about the program help you
get enrolled
and we'll leave this open for about 15
seconds longer
oops what happened
hold on a second I hit the wrong button
I apologize for being
so am fisted today
one moment
yes
all right here we go
all right
here we go
apologize for that you could answer that
question I'll give it about 20 seconds
close in about
five four
three two
one
and it's a 50 50 split
so for those of you who answered yes we
will be reaching out to you and sending
you a proof of attendance
helping you with questions about the
program
I want to thank you all for being here I
want to thank Greg for his knowledge his
expertise his time and his patience
really appreciate that Greg
yep no problem thanks for having me
and I want to thank everyone in our
audience the QR code will take you to
the program page on our website
and
you can of course contact a learning
consultants and ask us at
simplylearn.net we hope that we can
welcome you into the Caltech and simply
learn learning community and please go
to the website you can navigate from
there to other resources about cloud
computing
um and
delve into everything that we have
available for you so if you're not in
the United States if you're in India
Africa Asia Europe
anywhere in the world
you'll see other offerings that we have
available in your local area we operate
in 150 countries worldwide
so we again hope we can welcome you into
our learning community
that concludes our webinar for today